[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors quatre jours seulement après l
incendie qui a ravagé notre dame de
paris tel vin tf1 et elle va bientôt
peut-être vont passer 20e chef c'est ça
tf1 bouleverse ses programmes et propose
ce soir un qui veut gagner des millions
spécial notre dame alors c'était une
annonce qui a été extrêmement critique
et toute la journée on vous a fait un
recap voilà de ce qui s'est passé et
regarder aujourd'hui sur les réseaux
sociaux tout le monde s'en est pris à
tf1
alors nous on voulait me suivre là on
sait qu'on n'est pas hyper potes on va
dire la vérité ici et c'est vrai que là
plein ici qui veulent prendre la défense
aussi de tf1 par rapport à des gens qui
les ont critiqués par rapport à cette
contre-programmation regarde alors que
le monde entier a assisté impuissant à
l'embrasement de la toiture de
notre-dame lundi soir un milliard de
dons ont été versés par deux grandes
familles françaises et par de nombreux
anonymes pour contribuer à sa
reconstruction
cette fois la chaîne tf1 souhaite
apporter sa pierre à l'édifice après les
10 millions d'euros de dons de son
président la première chaîne bouscule
ses programmes et propose ce soir de
façon imprévue un numéro spécial de qui
veut gagner des millions au profit de
notre dame pour notre dame de paris ce
soir tf1 se mobilise pour un qui veut
gagner des millions
exceptionnel mais si cette émission
spéciale en champs de certains
téléspectateurs beaucoup d'entre eux
crient au contraire au scandale et
accuse tf1 de vouloir surfer sur
l'actualité pour faire le buzz et faire
de l'audience
car si la totalité des gains remportés
lors de ce programme iront en effet à la
reconstruction de la cathédrale
tf1 ne s'est pas exprimée concernant les
importantes sommes d'argent générées par
la publicité durant la diffusion du
programme
alors les internautes qui critique qui
veut gagner des millions spécial notre
dame
j'aime ou j'aime pas alors j'aime j'aime
pas donc je vous le dis journée spéciale
alors donc avec des appels aux dons
aussi sur tf1 on avait tous les
animateurs qui appeler aux dons et je
vous le dis même cette séquence des
animateurs qui appeler aux dons a
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup fait réagir
alors ils ont essayé de réunir des gens
et c'est vrai qu'ils ont le casting on
va pas se mentir il n'est pas ou parce
que c'est que des gens qui n'ont réuni
que les mecs qui avec et voilà voilà
qu'ils avaient sous la main donc arthur
laurence boccolini a les sensations et
grégoire margotton fauve hautot chris
marquès qu'on aime énormément voilà et
anne claire coudray harry roselmack
série dollars 2 le casting c'est que des
gens de tf1 parce que ils ont dû monter
ça en deux jours elle est ce que vous
aimez ou est-ce que vous n'avez pas ces
chaussures les réseaux est ce que vous
comprenez cette résurrection sur les
réseaux sociaux qui ont beaucoup
critiqué valérie bella
oui je comprends l'exaspération des
tweetos parce que en depuis l'incendié
on est déjà un milliard un milliard de
dons donc c'est vrai que dans les mois
effectivement tout de suite on s'est dit
c'est formidable les grandes fortunes se
sont mobilisés et c est donc mais
évidemment je peux comprendre que les
gens se disent attendait en fait une
émission spéciale il ya un milliard déjà
sur la table et on fait une émission en
plus spécial et et pour d'autres causes
à ce moment là pour d'autres drames
pourquoi tf1 de se mobiliser suprême un
gorille ce que vous êtes en prime en
face aux résultats en direct vous seront
en direct dans un instant non mais oh
oui là c'est avec ça c'est une blague
mais c'est vrai que voilà il ya plein de
gens qui ont mal réagi à d'autres causes
on se dit pourquoi ils ont pas réagi et
fernand qui veut gagner des millions
spécial tel ou tel pied par les
décomptes et enfin avoir compris cela
était bien là franchement les pompiers
il a perdu une belle cagnotte
honnêtement les gens sont à mon avis un
peu écoeuré par ce qui est très bien
attention s'être aimés qui 20 milliards
tant mieux tant mieux mais après je
comprends que les gens soient un peu un
un peu écoeuré et surtout s'interroge
sur le fait qu'on ait pu avoir autant
d'argent en si peu de temps qui est une
bonne chose et pourquoi refaire une
émission franchement les pompiers ça a
été parfait jean-michel oui moi je
trouve surtout qu'ils ont ici voulait
donner l'argent pouvait donner l'argent
sans faire une opération de
communication autour d'un jeu comme ça
qu'on pouvait très bien décider dès lors
une grande chaîne on donne un million
d'euros voilà pour eux comme ça c'est la
promotion d'un jeu quand il a aidé à
donner 10 millions bouygues à martin
bouygues
c'est vrai il avait alors juste là il ya
plein de gens qui se posent la question
c'est est-ce que là les recettes
publicitaires - là notre dame du nord
voiture n'était pas du tout mine de rien
ce qui choque les gens je vous le dis
c'est que tf1 puisse gagner de l'argent
ce soir en faisant ils émissions qu'ils
ont déprogrammé et qui est une émission
sera pas lorsque caritatives
donc ça va alors ça va leur centième des
programmes et leurs séries donc ils vont
avoir une série en plus qui vont pouvoir
mettre plus tard et c'est ce que je vois
c'est que les gens disent est ce qu'ils
vont donner l'argent des recettes
publicitaires
c'est non voilà je vous dis c'est non
mais il se trouve que ça serait une
formidable occasion pour tf1 justement
de garder leur émission classique
puisque c'était faux c'est la chaîne qui
donne le plus de visibilité aux
associations ferait donc justement
c'était l'occasion de se démarquer comme
valérie a dit ils ont déjà un après moi
je me fais l'avocat de tf1
il ya plein de gens aussi qui disent
alors quand on fait quelque chose on
nous critique quand on fait rien on nous
critique aussi ce que dit benjamin les
pompiers par exemple s'en était
formidable c'est en corrélation et
c'était formidable n'y avait pas une
urgence absolue
faire les affaires de cette émission là
maintenant alors on le dit aussi ce qui
s'est dit ou tissus réseau je vous dit
tout c'est que les mecs disent ah bah
comme par hasard ils à mettre le jeudi
parce qu'ils sont un peu plus chers avec
section de recherches lui ont pas mis ce
vendredi bastia on savait qu'ils avaient
koh-lanta et l'ont pas mise samedi
hassani parce que y'a de vote
oui j'ai vraiment et après il a non moi
ça moi ça me gêne aussi parce que c'est
on a on a parlé moi j'ai entendu partout
pour refaire notre dame il parlait de
400 à 500 millions pour refaire on est
déjà à un milliard 26 à 25 cents us ils
vont pas refaire à l'identique
il ya des pièces dans notre dame il
parlait les mecs les spéciales j'ai
écouté à la radio penche train de
conduire
il ya des pièces de l'envergure d'une
twingo tu ne cesses degli aller par
ailleurs ryan white une twingo le bois
le bois en forêt qui n'existent on n'a
même pas oui c'est ça donc ils sont en
train de dire on est ce qu'on remet la
flèche est ce qu'on remet pas la flèche
il parle de refaire avec du métal est
pas du bois il parlait de 400 à 500
millions là on est déjà un milliard ma
question qui veut gagner des millions
combien ils vont faire gagner ce soir à
l'émission là au plus au meilleur des
cas saumade meilleur des cas ou max max
servie de son vélo et tu veux pas dire
vraiment ces deux cent mille euros qui
va remettre notre message rien ça sur sa
chasse est d'accord 200 me lancer une
opération de com mais ils sont là mais
ils ont le mérite de le faire mais oui
mais alors c'est pour autre chose faite
parfaitement les pompiers sa raison
d'être en dessous parce qu'on peut faire
plein de choses avec un milliard notre
dame ice on la répare et où il faut la
remettre en état n'y a pas de souci
là-dessus y a pas de débat mais il ya
des trous environ il ya des femmes qui
sont qui sont battus qui sue qui sont à
la rue qui peuvent pas parce qu'ils
n'ont pas d'odeur
il ya plein d'autres et bien là et après
on est d'accord ou mémoire et mons et
c'est mon pote et il est un peu comme
moi il y beaucoup et parle beaucoup avec
les gens voilà il rencontre dans la rue
ce qui les lie les chauffeurs livreurs
et je vous dis la vérité
moi ya plein de gens qui me disent
attend les gilet jaune et ça fait quatre
mois qu'ils sont qui sont dans la rue
ils demandent des trucs
alors après non mais après on nous
critique pas du tout ceux qui ont donné
et moi je critique même pas tellement
les gens ne parle même pas des gilet
jaune moi les gens qui me parlent d'un
rêve que je semble travail dans cette
phase il devient par les chutes mais là
aussi vous accomp le travail même si on
le travaille aussi les gens me disent
vous rendez compte que l'humain il passe
après la pierre c'est des morceaux
pierre notre dame et précis mais ça
c'est ton point de vue
oui chérie mais cheryl est sûre avec isa
azare isa la fondation abbé pierre tu
connais jacques magie je connais rythme
d'un milliard c'est trente ans de
fondation abbé-pierre saab et pierre si
tu te mets un milliard à fond d'affaires
des piats énorme ses 30 ans oui mais sur
sept
alors chers frères et mon si je peux me
permettre c'est bon aussi
c'est vrai que tous ceux qui ont donné
aussi y jouer au vrai pour le patrimoine
français via voilà cependant si après
réparé dans nos mails allant là
j'aimerais qu'on revienne sur le débat
et va vous allez en dire de même plus
que deux parce que la peau nettement
j'en ai marre de ce débat il ya l'église
d'un côté et les sdf dans la rue
personne ne fera jamais ici autant que
les prêtres et les religieux les noces
rebelles des critiques battisti se fait
toutefois les prêtres le pauvre a dit
l'elysée les gens puissants ce qui donne
de l'argent à lire les tragédies hors
norme et oui on s'adapte de façon ornans
là pour protéger quand j'ai dit oh bah
ouais d'accord c'est à dire que tout ce
qui donne ce sont les bienvenus peu
importe le supprimer mais refuser la
machine les actifs éthique la spéciale
j'aime j'aime pas j'aime pas l'heure est
à l'union et à la solidarité et pas aux
petites polémiques là typiquement le
hasard du calendrier faisaient qu'il
était en pleine session d'enregistrement
qui veut gagner des millions
brièvement directeur de programme tu dis
allez on va en profiter pour le faire on
vient au moment du coup nous cause
nationale quand même c'est bien que des
médias se mobilisent regarder alors je
vais vous dire dès 8 heures mdr t'es fou
qui va diffuser un qui veut gagner des
millions spécial notre-dame ou comment
se faire du fric sur une tragédie
notre dame de paris jusqu'à faire un qui
veut gagner des millions faut pas non
plus pousser le bouchon trop loin tf1
qui veut gagner des millions
emmanuel macron c'est plus qu'un fossé
qui s'est encore créé avec les français
face à l'intérêt de ce monument tout
part en vrille que ce soit des
programmes de l'argent et des valeurs
n'ont par contre là ça devient ridicule
toutes les émissions spéciales sur notre
dame les animateurs de tf1 qui appelle à
donner de l'argent
on est dans une autre dimension ok
l'incendié dramatique mais maintenant
stop
ils ont déjà un milliard d'euros de dons
sur l'a2 samedi soir sur ce twitt lâche
sur ce twitt là je suis assez d'accord
avec les critiques des initiatives de
france 2 de faire une émission spéciale
salaire soit aussi non mais c'est pareil
siemens est un appel aux dons et 2 c'est
une émission va revenir sur version
dames où il va garder les java qui tue
cochon c'est là que tu sais stéphane
bern qui va prénom pas que ça rajoute
expliqué plein de choses
nous allons faire partie d'ailleurs tout
à fait on est devant ce soir voilà il
vous êtes très fier de ferveur samedi
soir par non oui il ya 2 sur france
télévisions il n'y a pas de recettes
publicitaires merci barça bon alors
c'est l'erreur
voilà bonsoir à la cause alors et quand
elle est jolie et france télévisions
quand ils ont de la pub généralement
jouer dit il demande au csa de reverser
à la cause donc voilà le thé les hawks
et voilà oui kevin hommage tout cas
après on parle de coups de base mais je
pense que moi pour moi le meilleur coup
de buzz ça aurait été qu'ils donnent
c'est justement cet argent parce que du
coup la nature qui donne cet argent
justement aux pauvres et je pense que ça
aurait fait plus parler d'eux pour le
nom me donne beaucoup de ce qu'il faut
c'est mieux à deux heures sur cette
nature il le faut sociation qui veut
gagner des millions
mais cette année moi j'ai entendus me
suis je moi j'aurais dû cette année le
téléthon ça a été en baisse et alors ils
sont après le téléthon ça c'est grâce
aux téléspectateurs djoudi le téléthon a
fini à 85 millions euros donc bravo à
vous parce que ils s'en sont sortis à la
fin et je vais venir en salle et lyon
c'est moins sont elles aussi en voilà
alors bas mais on va voir ce qu'on
pensait téléspectateurs aiment bien page
m32 prend j'aime pas 68%
donc c'est assez tromper